this
is a press conference being given or a
press statement
being made by the leader of hamas
in the light of the attacks on gaza and
the
subsequent ceasefire which went into
effect in the early hours
of february let's listen to what he has
to say
this greatness
bravery
first and foremost
in jerusalem west bank 1948
territories they all marched towards
al-aqsa mosque to protect and safeguard
the holy site
with their bare hands to prove to the
whole world
that al-aqsa is ours jerusalem is ours
and the palestinian people the whole
nation cannot give up on it
al-aqsa mosque
the road to our prophet's accession to
heaven
the resistance lived up to the
aspiration of the palestinian people
praise and glory to god almighty as
he continues to bestow on us
new hopes opening
new horizons for a new cycle
the epic center is the palestinian cause
the focus is jerusalem
why not it is the first of
the two qiblas for the muslim nation
and it is the road through which our
prophet
took in his assistion to heaven
to our palestinian people and to
all free men worldwide
i bring to you this good news
good news of victory
strategic complex
and compound
by the palestinian people supported by
all three honest men
this victory was bestowed on us
by the grace of god
the merciful the almighty no victory
but that bestowed by god almighty
the all-knowing the old wise if
you are granted victory you
cannot be defeated it is true
it is a divine victory
why not why not
as gaza the defiant gaza
together with the defiant gazans
have rose
to the holy sites and to our people in
the 1948
territories who are living
in the thick of the fray
we rose to defend them
and to be in their support it is
a victory carved
by the noble blood of the fallen martyrs
and
holding steadfast in the face of the
belligerent
hostilities perpetrated by
the israeli occupation forces chiefly
among
them as they didn't
joined hands
heavy blow to the enemy this blow
will leave an indelible mark
on the israeli occupation forces on
their political
security and military institutions
we salute our resistance
and their leadership
assisted by his brothers in the
leadership
of the movement and our
other fellow palestinians the leaders of
the brigade
whose name was chanted by
millions in jerusalem
in the holy site following
the prayers gathered
thousands gathered to pray to god
almighty
to bless the resistance
and the leadership of this fearless
brave honest man muhammad
his name echoed in the holy site a
thousand chanted his name
despite the fact that they have
never met him or even
seen
along with his fearless brave men of the
resistance
and other leaders of the resistance
factions
unless the holy sites and the entire
soil of the palestinian
territories are liberated
yes today we are standing today
with our heads held high before
those fearless
brave leaders some of them has fallen as
martyrs
like jamal zebda and other fellow
martyrs
then the list
our brave resistance fighters who are
standing steadfast
i begin saying that jerusalem
is the center of the struggle
the first
this is a message to our enemy the
israeli occupation forces
and to the whole world that
jerusalem is the center of our struggle
and we cannot relent
until
history
our spirit our faith our
future the first of
the two qiblas of the muslim nation
it is the heart of our civilization
the one in the past and the one to come
the second issue i wanted to address is
gaza it was gaza and the gazans
who stood as a guarding shield
defending jerusalem glorious gaza
and the gazans for the fourth time
standing in defiance without
as our prophet once said to his
companions
who is to carry this sword
for me
one of the companions stepped forward
and the prophet handed over the sword to
him
yes it was gaza and the gazans
who carried the sword
they stood as a guarding shield
defending
the holy site they have dealt
a heavy blow to the enemy
despite the geographical distance
between
this lesson it is the beginning
gazans the resistance are the guardian
shield
of jerusalem and the whole palestinian
territories
we have dealt a heavy blow to the enemy
weed their calculations
and a third issue i wanted to address
is that the blessed resistance
is ever more robust than ever
more powerful and before
all we have our unshaken
belief our firm conviction
we have employed all our creativity
in defense and in the offense
we will going to grow
and we will continue to grow more robust
simply because we are defending a noble
cause
a national one it is
the cause to liberate our occupied
territories
and free our prisoners
what happened is nothing but a strategic
victory simply because what's
to come is no doubt different
from what was before it ushered
into new
era more victories will come
more successes will come
more strategies will be built
that's why we consider that
this battle was a paradigm shift
gigantic leap in our struggle
against the zionist enemy
epic victory has disturbed
the calculation of the enemy and that's
why
our people our resistance
and our fellow supporters
are now prepared for a new era
it is the post jerusalem sword
operation it is a divine victory
it is a strategic victory that's why
i called it it is a compound victory
at the internal level at the region 11
and at the ban islamic level it is
a strategic victory as the whole
palestinian territories
all the palestinian people across all
our territories
have come together in west bank
and in gaza
more than 28 palestinians
have fallen as martyrs in their march
towards al-aqsa mosque
our palestinian communities in jordan
and lebanon we have all come
together it is a palestinian
islamic and regional victory
once and once again i praise
god almighty for this blessed victory
what's next
with the preliminary calculations
following
this battle and after all the facts
established
and new realities on the ground to all
our people on all three honest men
worldwide
that we are required to work
on different paths
first our resistance
is the shortest way towards
has destroyed the deal of the century
the falsehood mongered by the enemies
it has destroyed
all the force aspirations penned our
normalizations
with the israeli occupation forces
that's why once again it is only
resistance
that is the shortest course towards
liberation
second it is our unity the unity of the
palestinian people within
and without within and beyond
all the palestinian people have come
together one
united body around
their resistance
we will continue to embark on these
huge efforts in order to achieve
a true genuine unity
at the level of all the national
institutions
and here this spirit
of resistance should be instilled across
our territories
simply because this battle has ushered
us
into a new era of unity
a third important issue is two
main fences with our arab and regional
neighborhood
we have all witnessed how all the people
in the region
with their various and different
political
affiliations they have all come
together supporting palestine and
resistance
and here i call on all our arab
muslim and regional countries to come
together
and take part in building a
comprehensive strategy
on how to move forward
and how to restore our equilibrium
we should
reinforce our relations with the
international community
we have all witnessed the huge
change in the narrative and rhetoric
all across the globe even
inside the united states we have seen we
have seen massive protests
in many capital cities worldwide calling
for an end
to the zionist occupation and
restoration of the palestinian people's
rights
we are required to cement
our relations with the international
community and world
world states finally
who paid the heaviest
sacrificing every deer for the sake
of jerusalem
it was us who paid the heaviest price
and we as the leader of the movement
together with our good honest true
palestinians
and all honest men worldwide
will rebuild gaza
we will rebuild and restore
what has been destroyed by the zionist
enemy
we will restore our
normal way of life
we cannot relent we cannot
give up on our responsibilities
towards our prisoners the relatives of
the martyrs
and our institutions we cannot relent
until this noble goal is achieved
until the unjust siege
is broken and here this unjust siege
that has been laid to us for more than
15 years
must come to an end
to conclude i wouldn't fail to remember
to thank and salute all those
who supported us supported jerusalem
supported al-aqsa mosque chiefly our
brothers
in the arab republic of egypt who have
been
with us from day one playing their
historical
instrumental role in curbing
the israeli aggression doing all what
they could
to put an end to the aggression we will
remain together
and also we thank the state of qatar
for playing an instrumental role
through their diplomacy we have been in
daily contact
with his royal highness the emir of
qatar
and the foreign ministry of qatar
we also thank the united nations in
their coordination with
both egypt and qatar to have
the belligerent hostilities coming to an
end
and also we thank all those who provided
arms to the resistance factions
namely the islamic republic of iran
thank you to all the arab and muslim
states i wouldn't
fail
and to them i promise from
one victory to another
we will continue in our struggle until
we will
all be able to freely
offer prayers and the holy mosque of
al-aqsa
may god almighty
accepting his mercy the fallen martyr
and
grandspeed recovery to all the winter
thank you